running after these days got a
girlfriend no like I don't like getting
pushy
hearing the word [ __ ] come out of your
mouth does make me question whether or
not I like it back again
I'm never gonna meet a woman who
understands me I don't think I've heard
of a man ever who wanted to be in a
relationship so badly besides Drake I'm
talking views Drake
I feel like Beauty straight alone on a
building dangling my legs off wondering
what it's like to feel companionship
okay but you're not getting five stars
Uber driver I mean honestly you guys are
twins oh my God wait she really does
look like me
I'm sorry this was insane let me make it
up to you you're dating a black girl
I've never felt so understood by
somebody in my entire life whether you
like it or not we kind of go together
now you're my boo come on
ask her to marry me do you plant outdoor
family yeah I just haven't had the
chance to meet them what's going on tell
me about life how are you
this is your white granddaddy come back
and haunt me what
do you want to marry my daughter
yes yes I do well Ezra
you could try
can you honestly say that your family is
excited to have my black ass in the
picture
oh my gosh you are so beautiful I think
the police okay are [ __ ] up towards
black people I like your braids thank
you exhibit head braids
the difference between me you've built a
pretty awesome life together we just
need to protect it
oh so you're all Muslim very much so I
love it this goofy that I'm wearing was
actually a gift from The Honorable Louis
Farrakhan are you familiar with The
Minister's work well I'm familiar with
what he said
your family my family
[Music]
I don't know how this is gonna work well
we were technically OG slaves are you
trying to compare the Holocaust to
slavery potatoes our people came here
with nothing like everybody else they're
very uncomfortable conversation
what's the difference between
me hey uh what's up with white girls
am I white guys
well I'm not I'm white guys for sure
[Music]